Thank you to all involved
in our clinical trials.
♪
PETE: THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
LOSING COMPLETE CONTROL OF THE
SURGE OF MIGRANTS RUSHING OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER, BUT WHO DO THEY
BLAME?
>> WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
INHERITED IS A BROKEN SYSTEM AT
THE BORDER.
>> THE 11-YEAR HIGH FOR
CROSSINGS WITHOUT DOCUMENTATION
AT THE BORDER WAS IN THE MIDDLE
OF TRUMP’S PRESIDENCY.
THIS IDEA THAT IT’S JOE BIDEN’S
ELECTION THAT HAS PROMPTED MORE
PEOPLE TO SHOW UP BELIED BY A
ACTUAL FACTS.
>> JOE BIDEN INHERITED A HUGE
MESS ON IMMIGRATION.
>> WHAT WE ARE SEEING TODAY IS
THE CONSEQUENCE OF FOUR YEARS OF
DISMANTLING EVERY SYSTEM IN
PLACE TO ADDRESS THIS WITH
HUMANITY AND COMPASSION.
PETE: AS WE SAW YESTERDAY, THE
TALKING POINTS WENT OUT, AND
THEY WERE CLEAR.
LET’S BRING IN RETIRED ABOUT
ACTING I.C.E. DIRECTOR TOM
HOMAN.
TOM, GOOD MORNING.
YOU HEARD IT, THEY SAY THEY
INHERITED A MESS AT THE BORDER,
AND THAT’S WHAT WE’RE SEEING.
>> LOOK, THE FACTS ARE THEY
INHERITED THE MOST SECURE BORDER
I’VE SEEN IN MY CAREER, PETE,
WHICH HAS SPANNED OVER THREE
DECADES.
THAT IS A FACT.
IN 2020 THE ALIEN CHILDREN, THE
NUMBERS ARE NOW 70% FROM YEAR
PRIOR.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION’S NOW 50-80%
DEPENDING WHAT MONTH YOU LOOK
AT.
AND LAST MONTH BIDEN’S POLICIES
HAVE CREATED A 300% INCREASE.
WHAT’S REALLY KISS TURNING IS
YOU HAVE -- DISTURBING IS YOU
HAVE CHRIS MURPHY WHO IS THE
CHAIR OF THE HOMELAND SECURITY
COMMITTEE, AND HE DOESN’T KNOW
WHAT’S GOING ON AT THE BORDER?
EITHER HE DOESN’T KNOW OR HE’S
LYING ABOUT IT WHICH NEITHER ONE
IS A GOOD LOOK WHOSE JOBS JOB IT
TO SECURE THE HOMELAND.
THE HOMELAND IS NOT SECURE.
THE BORDER’S NOT SECURE BECAUSE
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
UNDONE THE SUCCESS OF TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
EDUCATE YOURSELF.
GIVE ME A CALL.
I’LL TELL YOU THOUSAND FIX IT.
YOU CAN’T GO ON NATIONAL TV AND
SAY THIS IS PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
FAULT.
PETE: DO YOU THINK THEY KNOW AND
THEY DON’T CARE?
ARE THEY WILLFULLY BLIND TO IT?
WHAT IS THE REASON WHY THEY
WOULD LOOK AT SOMETHING LIKE
THIS AND NOT RATIONALIZE THAT
IT’S A CRISIS AND THEN BLAME
TRUMP?
>> BECAUSE THEY CAN’T ADMIT TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT THEY
PLANNED THIS CRISIS.
WHEN JOE BIDEN MADE PROMISES
DURING THE CAMPAIGN OF ENDING
I.C.E. CAN DETENTION, ENDING
REMAIN IN MEXICO PROGRAM, GIVE
AMNESTY AND DACA AND HEALTH
CARE, WHEN YOU MAKE THOSE TYPES
OF PROMISES, YOU KNOW THEY’RE
GOING TO COME.
YOU CAN’T GO ON NATIONAL TV AND
SAY WE SOLD OUT AMERICA TO WIN
AN ELECTION.
JOE BIDEN CAN’T SAY I FOLDED TO
THE LEFT TO GET VOTES AND GAVE
UP THE SECURITY OF THE BORDER.
AGAIN, THE MOST SECURE BORDER
WE’VE EVER SEEN UNDER PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
PETE: TOM, THE DHS ORDERED FEMA,
WHICH USUALLY DEALS WITH, AS YOU
KNOW, FLOODS, STORMS AND OTHER
THAT’SES, IS THAT AN ADMISSION
WHEN YOU CALL IN FEMA?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
ACTIONS SPEAK LOUDER THAN WORDS,
AND THEIR MISSION STATEMENT,
HELPING PEOPLE BEFORE, DURING
AND AFTER A CATASTROPHIC
DISASTER OR CRISIS.
SO SENDING FEMA TO THE SOUTHERN
BORDER, GUESS WHAT?
ALL THE CARDS ARE ON THE TABLE
NOW.
IT IS A DISASTER, AND IT IS A
CRISIS AND, LOOK, UNDER BIDEN --
NOT JUST ON CHRIS MURPHY, I’VE
NEVER SEEN ANYONE WEARING A
TRUMP SHIRT COMING ACROSS THAT
BORDER.
THIS IS BECAUSE JOE BIDEN AND
HIS POLICIES, PERIOD.
PETE: CATASTROPHIC DISASTER IN
THE MISSION STATEMENT THE, YOU
CALLED THEM IN AND THEN YOU
WON’T EVEN CALL IT A CRISIS.